وأن القوات وسكان الكيبوتس شاهدوها في الوقت الحقيقي
الساعة 4:20 بعد الظهر أكثر من تسع ساعات
بعد أن اخترق مئات من إرهابيي الأحياء لي وآري
النزاهة في الكيبوتس تشتعل وأنا أشاهد الآن
باري: على الجانب الشمالي أرى عمودًا من الدخان
وفي الجزء الشمالي الغربي الذي أمام المقبرة هناك
هذا هو الوشق النهائي هاياو هاياو الذي تم توثيقه
أضف أمامنا حجم القتال وعدد الإرهابيين
غير المطبوع الذي استولى على الكيبوتس قام بتوثيقه
خزان العميل في منزل شرائط التوثيق الجديدة
يكشف أنه التقى بشكل رهيب في اتجاه منزل بيسي بالفعل
الساعة 5:30 نهارًا، بعد ساعة ونصف من وصولهم
والقوات المتوجهة إلى المنطقة من المقاتلين الذين بقوا هناك بأعداد كبيرة
كانت تلك أول طلقة تحذيرية تلتها الدبابة
أصيبت ووصلت دبابة أخرى أكملت مهمة هوبا
كان هناك
يحذر